good morning millennials
welcome back to the chose happy Tuesday
uh shook that it's only Tuesday hey Jax
are you feeling shook as well
I'm not as shook as you because I was
acutely aware of the day of the twos but
I am shook for a few other reasons one
we're just the hair girls today yeah la
turia got a haircut and her hair is
bouncing you know what it's so you know
it's a huge part of I think growing up
is realizing what you want in a haircut
and just asking for it as opposed to
like going home and crying you know
yeah for me when I get a haircut it's
like I'll say what I want and yes in
general like please follow what I say
but it's like if you take off a little
too much like
I'm not complaining oh for me end of the
world like even if I don't like how it
looks
I know it'll grow back and it's like
it's fun to see myself with these
different hair lengths like it's only
been feeling myself otherwise like you
know if I'm if I'm feeling confident
maybe right now isn't the time to like
chop off on my hair but if I'm feeling
myself like I feel like you're feeling
yourself I am you know what McClure do
your worst I got a great haircut I just
want to say and if anybody is feeling
inspired by my haircut this is what I
asked for and I feel like it took me a
while to figure out like what the right
thing to ask for was my hair had gotten
a little long but the link didn't bother
me so I said for the length
just to trim I think I did like two
inches just the dead nothing crazy but I
wanted like lots of layers so my [__]
strands are now like you know
banging they're really short I have lots
of movement all my hair is different
lengths but the overall length of my
hair is still I have still have long
hair yeah that's what I say too I say
cut the dead I used to be like leave the
dead I just want the length and they and
then they would cut the dead because
what hairdresser is going to leave you
with split ends and that's when I would
be disappointed honestly so now I say
cut the dead because we just want the
hair to balance I don't need it to be
down to my butt crack
cut the dead add layers
I have kept that mentality with my nails
like when I got my nails done they're
like you want to cut this Nail's broken
this one's not even I'm like no
keep the length like my my goal is to
always have long nails and like when I
get a manicure I'll have two long nails
two stubs one broken one that's so funny
yeah I used to do that too and then like
I would post a picture of my manicure on
Instagram and people would reply like
your nails are all different like people
be like is your index finger okay and I
would just be like I didn't know that
was a problem until you mentioned it
yeah and I'm not letting the haters get
me down like I love my uneven Nails you
know because I still got I got you know
a really long ring finger right now
um I've recently for the past few years
been on a stage where it's like one nail
is broken cut them all that's the
healthy thing to do and that's the
mature thing to do but I ain't that
mature
yeah so the hair is Herring
thank you I am coming on here with my
headband situation I don't know how it's
gonna look with the headphones but we're
trying new things you know we are like
you'll never know if you don't try it
looks good in person without headphones
like we'll see what's going on on the
screen but either way it'll be an
exciting change of pace we're just
experimenting with our looks recently
you know
are we you're never experimenting with
your looks one thing about me is I'm not
experimental
no but we're both wearing our hearts on
our chest today because we're both are
wearing sweaters with big chest symbols
mine is a heart on it because I'm giving
love I'm receiving love I'm in my loving
era yours is a bear on it what does that
mean to you because I'm just as sweet
and cuddly as a teddy bear I wouldn't
say cuddly but I'd say sweet
depends on the person no like you're
except Harry like you're not cuddly and
bro actually I would say you're more
cuddly with bro
because Brew loves to cuddle Harry you
know is constantly wiggling and we're
independent so he just wants to like
play can I tell you something like kind
of embarrassing that happened to me this
morning sure so I live very close to my
studio and during the Spring you know
fall Seasons I usually walk
it's so cold to New York it's been like
raining all week I was running late and
I'm just like fatigued you know so I
took an Uber okay now
I'm not going to underestimate how
frequently I take the Uber to work I do
when I could walk but today I get in the
car and the driver was like
do you take this ride every morning and
I'm like no
I'm like just like on days when it's
like really cold or raining he's like oh
okay and then he pulled up and he was
like I'm like oh right here is good he's
like oh you don't want me to make the
u-turn
I'm like have you driven me before
he's like yeah like three times like you
always I like lied to him that I never
take the Uber in the beginning and he's
like no I literally drive you every day
he must live near me or something yeah
when I used to be on the same route
every day in New York I did have the
same driver a few different drivers a
couple times no it's embarrassing when
like your commute is so short and like
you're still opting to take an Uber
because you're so [__] lazy
um I'm really it's like that's
definitely one of my resolutions is to
be
better with the walking but I have to
carry my laptop it's so heavy I need to
get a backpack or like honestly
a suitcase
or an Air Max what are those thin ones
called a MacBook Air well I will say I
do have a MacBook Air at the studio
that's what I'm using to talk to you
right now but I don't use it for our
post production because MacBook airs
like I have no storage I don't believe
honestly in MacBook airs I don't believe
in the air
brand and you know what yesterday when I
went to get my iPad for our Greta
approved green initiative she was like
which one do you want and I was like I
don't know the air is really light but I
just feel like air is like fraudulent
and she she like didn't disagree she was
like yeah
yeah if you want to download files like
definitely for our line of work you
can't have an air computer for the iPad
the only thing you would ever be
downloading is like shows when you're
traveling but still no I just I don't
know if it's like a conspiracy theory of
mine or there's any proof but like I do
not [__] with the air brand
okay I saw what she said I said what I
said
so
I don't know what we were talking about
but we're done talking about it yeah we
are my Uber driver
um
and that's a good segue yeah because
that's a great segue I don't have much
to catch up with you on I just I want to
know how your book club was titillating
titillating so be everything there from
the beginning and what are we reading
next month we haven't chose yet because
like I feel like we don't want to rush
you know like we want the book the book
to choose us
um so we read in five years I was raving
about it on the toast like two weeks ago
or a week ago you have literally the
concepts you call everything three to
four months ago when it was either eight
months ago or last week so it was last
week right yes I loved this book so much
I was so excited to go and talk about it
a lot of the people in the book club did
not like it
yeah that's what we experienced at the
redhead I will say though upon so we did
like um
Our Stars at the beginning like what
rating we gave it and then we also did
Stars at the end and a lot of people
like found that through the discourse of
the book and like finding deeper meaning
their rates went up
wow you're kind of shaking up the book
club mold Stars at the beginning and
stars at the end because you know what I
actually like there were certain things
in the book that really spoke to me
especially because like I'm always
interested in reading about people who
like have experienced grief and the girl
in the book has experienced two major
moments of grief one was a sibling she
lost extremely suddenly
and the second was like a best friend
slash almost sister who had like a very
slow illness and you have to watch the
person unravel and I feel like that's
like the two types of deaths and I feel
like whenever like we talk to people or
I talk to people about our dad passing
away they're always like you know well
at least he wasn't sick for a long time
it's like you find Solace and then
people who are experiencing grief with
somebody who's like going through an
illness and dying slowly they always say
well at least you have a chance to say
goodbye like there's like I feel like
we're always comparing those two
different types of death yeah and you
know what the book brought me a lot of
Peace because I think experiencing
someone you know slowly dying over an
illness and having to Grapple with their
death for months I think it's 100 worse
like and now I feel I feel at peace with
the grief that we had to experience as
kids honestly wow you're really
extrapolating a lot of meaning from this
book I was and actually a lot of my
friends in the um book club have
experienced grief and I think like
talking through it actually made them
like the book more
wow so I think I was changing hearts and
Minds I was like the book club wasn't
ready for me in my sermon no they were
not but you should tell your friends to
listen to the redheads if they didn't
like the book because they'll find a lot
of like-minded yes I will readers
they're constantly on my book club
spreading the good word of the redheads
trbc oh my God thank you so what's the
vibe for the next one I don't know I
know you guys like don't you probably
don't want to do like another romance no
we don't know like we honestly we were
having such a good conversation we
didn't get to talk about the next
month's book you know what you should
add to your list it's like it's
technically serious but it's an easy
read the Midnight Library that was
suggested
that is what you should read that was
suggested as well so and it's short it
was um it was gorgeous it was really you
know I love book club like it's good
sober fun
I've been trying to tell you you're
lettered mattered no I don't worry like
I know I'm watching dubstick next week
like don't worry
tonight what did Harry say about me not
much oh he was missing you but you were
on the FaceTime with him doing your Miss
Rachel thing I was I'm literally Miss
cloudy for Littles like
yeah you should put together a video the
way I could put a smile on these kids
faces it's not normal you should do a
video of you singing and talking maybe
yeah filming in the studio just like
Miss rage like what does she have that
you don't have nothing
overalls
go get them amazon.com and you have to
like find that what your like look is
what your fit I think the big heart
honestly is perfect I think this sweater
is perfection
it's Perfection for the littles and just
like do your thing I know I don't like
love like all the littles though like
just my own you know
you're not a camper file no I'm like a
I'm like if I'm related to I love you if
I don't know you like get away
all get away some are super cute yeah I
just like this love and like Obsession I
have in my heart with the nibblings like
I don't think that applies to children
in general okay so just pretend like
you're talking to your nibblings yeah
okay and then we can export that love to
others export it
export it exporting Littles yes so we
had a fun quiet night here and then I
just read I went to bed really early but
I read I was reading still you did yeah
I wanted to tell you about my book club
good I didn't even see them it was like
I'm 15 I'm like is this [__] sleeping I
was I was already asleep so nice
yeah it was nice uh and I my book put me
to sleep thanks hillbilly elegy
um also it's a big day here at the toast
Oscar Noms
yes nums are out nom nom nom lots of
thoughts we actually have a lot all the
stories today are really like celeb news
you know like no human interest no human
interest no crime no Sports nothing
Freaky Deaky too bad it's just like
really celeb gossip well that's our
bread and butter literally
and I'm excited to dive in I really am
okay so without further Ado here are the
past five stories that you need to know
that's true and today's episode is
brought to you by the one the only
bowling Branch all right you guys if
you're spending the winter season
however you're spending the winter
season make sure you're getting your
best sleep with a set of buttery soft
sheets from Bowling Branch made with the
softest 100 organic cotton that you've
ever felt it is the kind of quality that
you will feel immediately
immediately okay so Jackie and I have
been raving about bowling Branch long
before they've been sponsors our entire
home all of our sheets are bowling
Branch pillowcases duvet seats duvet
sets fitted sheets
flat sheets throw blankets they've got
everything from like the Staples to
accessories it's really good quality
it's a great investment in your home
um my guest room at Jackie's house has
bowling branch which is why I can spend
weeks on and they're completely
uninterrupted
um we both have the signature hemmed
sheets that's their best seller at
bowling Branch they use the highest
quality threads on Earth they're made
from slow grown organic cotton they have
a superior softness they're buttery to
the touch super breathable so they're
great year round whether it's the cooler
months or the warmer months they're
loved by millions of sleepers they have
tons of reviews like over 10 000 raved
reviews and they've been loved by three
U.S presidents and two Peabody
award-winning morning show hosts so
that's pretty good and one shorty Award
winner and shorty Award winner
and one gift of Life recipient of award
I won that award award recipient award
recipient so make the most of your
bedtime with the golden Branch sheets
get 15 off your first set of sheets when
you use promo code toast at bowling
branch.com that's bowling Branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch.com promo code toast today's
episode is also brought to you by Noom
when we decide to lose weight it's
usually not just about the number on the
scale whatever your reason is for
wanting to lose weight whether that's
you know just feeling better fitting
into your clothes anything new weight is
ready to help new weight is different
because they use psychology to help you
understand your eating habits and learn
how to make healthier choices every day
so if you're eating because you're bored
or you just can't pass up food when it's
free don't stress new weight can help
you break that cycle and change your
habits for good one of my favorite
things about Noom is their
psychology-based approach because so
much about weight and eating and your
habits is psychological it's just like
how you're wired and to unlearn a lot of
the things that you know like for me
eating when I'm bored or just like
Mindless snacking when I'm watching TV
is so like a core part of who I am and
Noom helps unravel that so their program
uses psychology they help you understand
the science behind your eating choices
and why you're craving what you're
craving they've helped more than four
and a half million people lose weight
everyone's journey is different so your
daily lessons that you get from Noom are
going to be personalized towards you and
your goals so the scientific principles
like cognitive behavioral therapy are
going to help you understand your
personal relationship with food the
program is super flexible because it
focuses on progress not Perfection so if
you slip up it's okay you don't have to
give up anything like if you love carbs
don't worry you can still eat carbs if
you're having cravings they can help you
lose the weight while still enjoying
your favorite food so stay focused on
what's important to you with new weights
psychology-based approach sign up for
your trial today at noom.com toast
that's n o o m.com slash toast to sign
up for your trial today and check out
their first book ever it's called the
new mindset it's a deep dive into the
psychology of behavior change it's
available to buy now wherever books are
sold maybe for your next book club 100
okay 100
don't let them forget I feel like this
might be a good time to remind some of
our new listeners I have two songs out
one is called toast and one is called
100 and they're both just like Bobs like
they're not you see my mug they're here
but they're really good you see my mug
always supporting you see my phone case
100% 100
foreign
okay our first story Oscar Noms came out
this morning at the crack of dawn and
here are the nominees in the big
categories
first best picture All Quiet on the
Western Front Avatar the way of water
the Banshees of innishiran Elvis
everything everywhere all at once the
fablemens tar top gun Maverick triangle
of sadness women talking oh sounds
Dreadful
um
so I haven't seen like any of the movies
except for Top Gun and Elvis and I don't
think either of those are gonna win nor
do I really think that they deserve to
um I've heard the triangle of sadness is
amazing I've heard everything everywhere
all at once is so good so maybe I'll see
them but I don't know I'm just like I'm
not an Oscar girly I'm not really like a
feature film girly okay neither am I but
I had a revelation recently because you
know how I was saying that when I watch
TV shows like I get too addicted and
then it's it sucks all my time and like
I I'm always thinking about it any free
time that I have like I'm not gonna do
anything productive I'm just gonna turn
on the TV I kind of think I should start
watching movies more because then it's
over like when I watch The Sound of
Music I broke it up into two nights and
then it was over and like what am I
going to be addicted to like reading
about Christopher Plummer online not me
not ever I feel like you actually are
I've been seeing your Instagram story I
am because I've been seeing some
conflicting stuff
um well actually I agree that um that
would be great for you so I think I'm
gonna watch as many of these movies as
are on demand like I wanna watch watch I
still haven't seen Top Gun I was
actually thinking last night like I
should treat myself oh my God it's such
a delight like a little popcorn a
hundred percent okay I'm gonna do that I
think I'll see um I'll watch the
trailers everything so I don't even know
what some of this stuff is about but
I've heard really good things about
everything everywhere all at once the
Banshees of innish year and is on every
single like list so I like but then you
know what's gonna happen is I'm gonna
watch something so terrible that I'm
gonna say this whole Enterprise is a
waste you're gonna say for that reason
I'm out yeah and I really want to see
the whale but I don't think it's
streaming it no it's not but I it is on
my list of things to do and Taylor
strecker said she wanted to see it with
me so like I'll have a day night at the
movies with Taylor so cute so yeah I
don't have a horse in this race yet
I only have two I have two horses in two
separate races
and like it makes me think back to like
two years ago when we were doing
whatever award shows Golden Globes
whatever and like dope stick was
nominated and I wasn't there like saying
dope six she Winks I didn't see it so
who am I to say that was very uh me
thing of you to do
which is what to like not watch Dope
Sick two years ago watch it now
like it wasn't like I was protesting on
you
okay I'm just saying like maybe I
shouldn't have an opinion on this if I
haven't seen every movie obviously
I know I don't have an opinion I only
have one I only have two opinions and
I'll tell you them when I get there
best actor Austin Butler Elvis Colin
Farrell the band she's of in ashirin
Brendan Fraser the whale Paul Mezcal
after sun Bill Nye hee living not Bill
Nye
not Bill Nye no
um obviously Brendan Fraser absolutely
has to win this it will be the greatest
ending to the biggest comeback in
Hollywood history I'm so happy for him
honestly even just getting the Oscar
nomination is huge so like he really has
one
um but it like I just I can imagine the
room if he wins I feel like everyone is
rooting for him like it honestly sucks
to be anyone else in this category yeah
you know what I feel like I've noticed
there's a trend in this year's award
cycle which I'm loving it's like these
actors who kind of fell off the map for
a little bit having a research and so
it's like Brendan Frazier Jennifer
Coolidge and key Hai Kwan from
everything everywhere all at once and
all of their speeches when they won were
like you know I thought it was over for
me like for kihai Kwan he had been like
a child actor and then like nothing
since and the director of everywhere
everything everywhere all at once I gave
him this opportunity and like same for
Jennifer Coolidge as she said like she
wasn't working and like Brendan Frazier
was on the outs with Hollywood and like
they're so grateful and they know what
it is to work and they know what it is
to not work and then to like come back
at this level like this is a trend I'm
loving seeing like justice for the
Elders of chills I love the way you just
described that it's so true like I feel
like for many years it's like the same
people winning the same Awards and it
gets like kind of monotonous and it's
like who's he the youngest who's the
freshest like yeah it's it's always like
the next next but we're never like going
backwards and like what about all these
established people who are so talented
and would love any opportunity to work
and have been like waiting for their
turn so true
so I I'm so rooting for Brendan Fraser
here like I will be so happy I haven't
even seen the movie but I have heard it
is incredible and he is like
heartbreakingly amazing in it I'm gonna
see it it is my one job before the the
award show yes like we need to see it
he's gonna be amazing but like I want
that speech from him of course because
like you know there's gonna be tears
unless you sneeze on it it's true thank
you but I think the whole room is just
gonna be like if the whole room is going
to be on there for you
yeah and if he doesn't win like I'm out
throw it away you know the only
acceptable person is kihai Kwan because
he's so cute he's in Best Supporting so
we can support everyone okay
so that's the first that's my first
horse in this race
okay best actress Kate Blanchette tar
Anna De armas blonde sure Andrea
risborough to Leslie Michelle Williams
the Fable men's Michelle yo everything
everywhere all at once I'm kind of
obsessed with Michelle yo like honestly
I'm choosing her I'm gonna watch that
movie
for my movie Nights yeah you know what
that's actually a movie The tailors I
was with them on Sunday they were like
you have to they were like screaming at
me like you have to see it oh really
okay great yeah
yeah I need it to become come personally
recommended from someone like not from
the academy who I had like nothing in
common with like true from like people
who I have common interests with like
what do you think will your girl like it
yeah the Taylors loved it and they also
loved the menu but I don't see that
nominated anywhere me neither but I've
heard about I think um Anya Taylor Joy
is in it so she's a joy to watch in
anything she's an Omnia Taylor joy to
watch yeah so I would watch that too but
not if it's not nominated it's not part
of my homework 100
best supporting actor Brendan Gleason
the band she's in ashiron Brian Tyree
Henry Causeway Judd Hirsch the fablemans
Barry keohan the Banshees of innishiran
kihai Kwan everything everywhere all at
once
yep that's my vote best supporting
actress Angela Bassett black panther
Hong Chow the whale Kerry Condon the
Banshees of innishirin Jamie Lee Curtis
everything everywhere all at once
Stephanie Sue everything everywhere all
at once
I don't care I don't care and a snub
here is Sadie sink in the whale oh
oh my god well I don't know if she was
any good but I imagine she was dazzling
we all saw her in all too well so true
and she didn't even speak I didn't speak
I just saw her at the Chanel Paris week
Fashion Week show she's like there's
like three it girls of Chanel this year
it's Lucy Boyton
Sadie sink
and get this apple Martin gwyneth's
daughter she's like making her coming
out debut as a Chanel girl okay I just
saw a photo of her I guess I hadn't seen
one recently
striking no it's like actually not fair
like it's it's like the word that's how
you know the world isn't fair because
Apple Martin she's super young that's
literally how she was born to look you
know that's that's her natural look her
mom is Gwyneth Paltrow her dad is
Coldplay she looks like that and in a
[__] Fair
yeah it ain't right
that you don't know you know what she's
going through yeah sure whatever but it
ain't Fair
um
yeah anyways that's cool of of Chanel
yeah no it's like a cool moment and I
love that for Sadie's saying so she's
probably like having fun and then like
her cheating get nominated for an Oscar
and was like kind of devastated but and
the whale wasn't nominated for best
picture so I don't even think that like
where will Brendan like sit it's not
tables so but like does she even get to
go
maybe she'll be a presenter because she
was in a movie where some you know like
the movie isn't nominated though so
you're right Brendan I hope he gets a
plus one why would he take her not her
oh I'm saying so he doesn't have to sit
alone of course he'll get a plus one
yeah no he should get like plus three
because he is like a wife and two kids
three kids three kids plus four
best animated film okay Guillermo del
Toro's Pinocchio Marcel the Shell with
Shoes On Puss in Boots The Last Wish the
Sea Beast and turning red
oh turning red is that the movie
Michaela likes about like the panda who
gets her period yes I just feel like if
you don't have campers on the council
like how are you choosing the winner for
this category this should be a parent
only like I don't care what some
I completely agree
yeah or parent a parent can choose yeah
because they've seen them over and over
again as well yeah
next best director okay who cares just
get to the song
best original song Applause from tell it
like a woman Diane Warren hold my hand
from Top Gun Lady Gaga lift me up from
Black Panther Rihanna not to not to from
rrr
um music by mm kiravani that's the song
that keeps winning I know and this is a
Lie from everything everywhere all at
once Ryan lot I haven't heard that not
two not two song that's winning
everywhere it's like I can't
say I can't speak to it but I feel so
passionately that Lady Gaga's hold my
hand is one of her like best songs I
cannot stop listening to it she so
deserves to win but I imagine that she
won't
yeah but she already has an Oscar right
yeah but like it still doesn't matter
like she should not I know I know less
right to loot to win because no no no no
no but like if this was her o on the
stop to egot and like she didn't win
that would be even more frustrating but
I'm just worried about egot for her like
I agree she deserves to win but at least
we get a live performance to pull my
hand oh true on the flip side of that
coin was snubbed
for Carolina it was a good song we don't
get a performance
it was I would still do that
no it it I wouldn't have it be the
winner he deserves to be nominated it's
a very beautiful song I agree perfect
original song for that movie I agree it
really captured the spirit of the movie
that's so interesting but does that mean
we're going to get a Rihanna performance
yep like there's no way yep I mean she's
gonna have a busy month right Super Bowl
so true
that's like a pop-in category in terms
of star power imagine if Taylor was in
there too Taylor Rihanna and Gaga and
not that it's about this but why
wouldn't the academy like want Taylor to
come to the show and perform and like
rated make their little show it's so
true relevant maybe they thought they
had enough star power with Rihanna and
Gaga
I don't know this feels like nasty nasty
totally just like nasty like someone had
out for her because she deserves to be
nominated has she been nominated for an
Oscar like beautiful ghost from cats
which was a terrible movie but he was
gracious let me look Taylor Swift
it's actually like a really good song
and I wonder I mean I don't know if this
is a thing but like could all too well
be nominated for a short film um I think
we would know if it was
all too well no
um
they're not making it easy to find so no
uh let me just look short
live action short I mean it's not there
yeah and I don't even know if it would
qualify but I kind of assume that it
would because she like entered in film
festivals and stuff
yeah it could
Taylor Swift's all too well isn't in the
running for an Oscar oh but she could
still win this was before the
nominations came out she could still
look for Carolina but then she didn't
it's an extent it's a scented music
video did not make the cut for Live
Action short that's despite a high
profile Oscars campaign that included a
screening in Swift's appearance so she
tried
sad
yeah damn all right well well those are
the Oscar Noms that you need to know do
we have a host
do we have a hose if we do we've
definitely reported it but who would be
like
last year was that like
Amy Schumer like the trio of women
yes yes it was actually very good it was
a goodness
about enough with these talentless hacks
like
I feel so strongly like even the ones
that I like I like Jimmy Fallon but like
the jimmies and these just like straight
white men who've had shows for 15 years
like they are not funny like when you
think of the talent like on the internet
like anyone had like be now with the
internet like anyone being able to just
like have a platform and get their
comedy out there when you think about
really the talent that's out there
we're still circle jerking the jimmies
and James like come on it's I don't
think I don't want an internet talent
for this honestly
no I know it okay but what I honestly
would be fine at this point because I
feel like hosting has just become like
this big thing where it's like nobody
wants to do it and also nobody's asked
to do it and then like when somebody
does it who's new they just kind of get
picked apart unless they're like
incredible which is really impossible
why can't we just have like someone who
is like uh textbook hosts like you know
Walter Cronkite like just someone rather
announce what's going on yeah either
they need to do that or like knock it
out of the park Ricky Gervais every year
yes yeah because he's excellent
Ricky Gervais should always hosts or
someone of that nature
that caliber and who's not afraid to
insult everyone in the room 100 percent
but the Oscars don't want that like the
Oscars are they're not like the Golden
Globes where it's a dinner and we're
laughing and we're drinking like the
Oscars are so serious so like have a
serious host like they don't need to
make us laugh listen why do we need to
laugh just tell us what's going on last
year with Amy Schumer why can't I
remember who else was in it
Amy Schumer
Regina Hall and Wanda yeah they were
actually hysterical
I didn't watch enough I watched I
believe I watched the whole thing I must
have been bored and it was good
I watched some of it because I remember
like we were just a few minutes behind
when the slap happened but also Harry
was just born slap yeah
yeah oh well whoever like is hosting
has to discuss that
yeah also uh Will Smith like wasn't
nominated for emancipation oh I didn't
even know he could film out
yeah so they will be held on Sunday
March 12th oh that's in a long time at
the Dolby Theater in Hollywood gorgeous
and they'll be on ABC so we'll see you
then
we'll see you then
that we will are you ready for our next
story
Shailene Woodley is speaking about her
breakup from Aaron Rodgers and she
seemingly refers to the breakup as the
darkest hardest time in her life that's
the same literally same same
Shailene Woodley found a creative Outlet
to work through a time when she was
struggling in her personal life the
actress told netaporte that filming the
upcoming Showtime series three women
based on the 2019 book provided
challenging during one of the darkest
periods of her life she said quote it
was hard to film because I was going
through the darkest hardest time in my
life it was winter in New York and my
personal life was [__] so it felt like a
big pain bubble for eight months I was
so grateful that at least I could go to
work and cry and process my emotions
through the character the show was
filmed between October 2021 and the
following May that February people
reported that Aaron and Shailene had
just ended their engagement they were
then spotted together again but then it
was confirmed that they broken up again
as we remember
I totally forgot that they were together
because like I've honestly blocked out
the trauma for me and the Heartbreak
that was such a fabulous couple like I
was obsessed even though like I'm not a
Shailene Woodley girl no and I wasn't in
Aaron Rodgers girl but together magic it
just like it made sense I I really
thought they were like together forever
I miss them I know now I'm just like
being reminded I'm glad she's opening up
you know and I'm glad she yeah she
experienced the relationship like as we
did as like a really kind of important
and serious relationship for her yeah
she also talked about like the
relationship being kind of her first
like famous relationship she said it
honestly never really hit me that
millions of people around the world were
actually watching these things and paid
attention to them then I dated somebody
in America who was very very famous it
was the first time that I had a
quote-unquote famous relationship and I
watched scrutiny opinions the desire for
people to know my life and his life and
our life it just felt violating in a way
that before it was fun she said I'm a
very private person and so I found that
anytime I posted anything I instantly
felt like I was sharing too much of Who
I Am with people I didn't necessarily
trust that's actually so true I didn't
even realize like how she hasn't had
like
any
like famous boyfriends
yeah couldn't be me like she risked it
all for the love of Aaron and you know
what it was good
they need to get back together it's the
world's not the same since they broke up
no it's definitely not but um I wonder
if like now she she wants to to continue
to date famous people or not like no
definitely not I know but there's also
like a
shared experience like I do feel it
brings you closer to get closer to a
person like no one in the world knows
what it's like to be like actually
famous except other famous people
yes
yes and I think because they were such
different types of Fame I think that
that worked yes but I think it could
also be really isolating to just be like
on this island with this person and
feeling like you can't trust anyone and
then like that's not really great either
or there's like always like a
competitive like Nick Lachey and Jessica
Simpson like there's a competitive
element to it too like you're comparing
but not when it's Aaron Rodgers and
Chile no she's why it was so good no I
was just saying like celebrity
relationships in general can have that
too
of course right like comparing how much
you're working to how much other person
is working and how many followers they
have and like just general comparisons
yeah in comparison is the thief of Joy
okay Teddy Roosevelt
thanks Teddy Teddy
Teddy row is about
row
oh oh Teddy row got it
thank you anyways Shailene
I don't know anyway get back to work go
make it work with Aaron people are
waiting the show looks good though yeah
loves a tv-based book she does face
television and she picks good projects
like she really does
yeah she's got a good picker yeah
next story a little music news Panic at
the Disco is breaking up as Brendan Yuri
confirms he's expecting his first baby
oh so Brandon Yuri put out a statement
on the um on his Instagram saying that
the band is splitting up and confirming
news that his wife is pregnant he said
it's been a hell of a journey but
sometimes a journey must end for a new
one to begin he said that said I am
bringing this chapter of my life to an
end and put my focus on energy on my
family and with that Panic at the Disco
will be no more wait that's kind of
crazy because literally Panic at the
Disco was on tour this year with Betty
who like I actually wanted to see it
like
so I feel like they were still actively
working they were doing like big
stadiums like that's kind of weird but I
also was under the impression like Panic
at the Disco was Brendan like he was
like his stage name like I know there
were other people in the band oh yeah
it's definitely a band type thing but I
don't think it works without Brendan
he's like Adam Levine
on the one hand like I'm sad about this
because I love Panic at the Disco like
their songs are just straight Bob's fire
but on the other hand like I don't
really get to complain because I've
never seen them in concert I don't
listen when they put out a new song like
who am I to say that no need to work
instead of be with your family no like
the like I think of the most recent band
breakup as like Rascal Flatts and it's
like that was devastating because like
we were out here streaming buying
tickets like we were doing everything to
support our favorite band and it wasn't
enough and it was like it came to a
grinding Hall it was like all of our
efforts weren't even noticed and it
didn't even matter but like with Pat I
mean same with Little Mix right
and it's like we went from four to three
and like I never let that change how I
felt never I never even mentioned it I
never said anything never
and then like it was them who said
but two of them had babies and they said
it was a break and I'm holding out hope
like why wouldn't they want to come back
no and they are still on good terms I
don't think between the three of them
there's they hang out all the time yeah
with like One Direction them going on
break like there was so much underneath
the surface between the guys like so
much and I just feel like we still don't
even know about but do you feel like
there was so much underneath the surface
lyrics yes
and it feels like with Little Mix like
there's a lot of Harmony there like
there's no acrimony
in acrimony s-a-t weird
um
so
goodbye Panic at the Disco yeah I wonder
if like Brendon Urie has enough money to
like just retire because that's what he
sounds like like I have kids now like I
don't want to work anymore
or like I have kids now not that he's
never gonna work again but like he'll
work on his schedule like doing you know
his songs with Taylor yeah and a song
Here a song there but like to be
responsible for a whole band when like
you're on your own timeline is a lot of
pressure so maybe now pressure's off
yeah maybe
or maybe there's more to the story yeah
there's always more to the story
ain't that the truth
are you ready for our next story only if
it's the next story oh that's brought to
you by like a newish sponsor that I'm
obsessed with honey love okay so I have
had honey love products for years be
long before they were sponsor of the
toast because I got to Target a Facebook
ad and like actually bought it and it
changed my life because I love a control
top underwear I love shapewear but I
find like so many of them make me
physically ill they make me nauseous my
stomach hurts and like they cut my night
short because I want to look smooth and
gorgeous but I'm wearing like an actual
rubber band around my waist
so we are finally this year stopping
wearing uncomfortable shapewear support
for today's episode comes from Honey
Love they have revolutionized
compression technology so you know no
longer have to feel like you're
suffocating while aware of wearing
effective shapewear you'll immediately
feel and see the difference and for a
limited time only you can get honey love
on sale get 20 off your entire order
with the code toast at honeylove.com you
could show your support for the toast
and check out honeylove.com using Code
toast so their best-selling product is
the superpower short it is the go-to it
has targeted compression technology that
distinguishes between areas where you
want to support and areas where you need
less compression their signature X
targets and sculpts your midsection
without squeezing your natural curves it
is designed to work with your body not
against it and I actually wore the super
power short to film my special I wore
them all throughout the year on tour I
cannot endorse these products enough I
feel like there's not many things I'm an
expert on but I feel as though I could
be an expert on shapewear comfortable
shapewear like yeah sure you can get
something you're an expert on shapewear
and you're an expert on Comfort yeah
like there's definitely shapewear out
there that like really will could put
you in the hospital like you take it off
and you're like I cannot believe I wore
that like how was I breathing and honey
love will make you look good and feel
good I cannot express I cannot
stress the importance of that
if you're struggling to take off a tight
piece of shapewear with a bathroom line
out the door say no more the super power
short has 100 cotton so you can skip the
extra undies plus it has a convenient
opening in the panty area for super easy
bathroom work
um there's no costume change required
they also have more than just sculpt
wear they have incredibly comfortable
bras tanks leggings treat yourself to
the best shape around the market save 20
off at honeylove.com with the code toast
that's code toast at honeylove.com
cinched snatched and lifted it's hot
girl season thanks to Honey Love
cinched snatched lifted
love that okay our next story is some
celeb gossip news new relationship for
Pete Davidson he is dating Chase Suey
wonders and they can't keep their hands
off of each other on vacation they are
co-stars in the I don't know what it is
show movie bodies bodies bodies and
they've continued to spark romance
rumors after they were spotted getting
handsy while wading into the crystal
clear Hawaiian Waters there's pictures
of them like smooching on the lounge
chair hugging in the ocean and it seems
that these two are very much an item
which is just crazy
like how quickly he moves on like I I
feel like at one point it was a joke but
I also feel like earlier like he took
appropriate breaks in between
relationships you know what I mean but
like to go from Kim which was a serious
relationship because as she said like
she's a serious girl
she had he has five tattoos of her he
got a branding because he said like this
shit's forever to break up from that
relationship and then just be like
dating emrata and then to break up with
them right now just to be Weeks Later
dating someone else like honestly I
don't think he was ever dating emrata
what do you think that was I feel like
honestly that was like kind of like a
move on emrata's part to like be spotted
out be relevant like stunt on her X-Man
I don't think these two were ever and
like Pete was happy to go along with it
like because he's a good guy
like I honestly I they were spotted at
the Nick game in a car and in some dingy
building like I don't know
so you think it was like fake or just
like friends I think it was like a
desperate move on emrata's part
but why would she say do that with him
because that's like what people care
about like you want to be spotted and
like make a make a statement to your ex
who cheated on you like you got Pete
Davidson like you know people are
obsessed not no if I'm at rata and I
want to stunt on my ex like I'm going
out with Brad Pitt all right so so easy
it is like for her so I just want to say
like I officially don't care about Pete
Davidson like I feel like there were a
few of his relationships that like I got
personally invested in like Ariana Kim
of course I kind of love the Kate
Beckinsale moment like I I can't give
any more of my heart to this man I don't
care and actually like it's it's kind of
tacky you know I'm gonna start talking
at him the way like we would talk about
a woman who's doing this yeah it's a
woman behave this way like the things
that people would say but I also find it
so weird that like girls still want to
be a part of this I know what I mean
like like I would you know if he were to
ask me out which like he really is doing
every single day like I'd be like no
Pete it's weird that like you need to
process your relationships like
and be single for a second be on your
own like how are you just gonna jump
into something with me when like how are
you not still thinking about Kim yeah no
I think this whole thing is weird like I
like this has been ever since Ari like
bde Pete Davidson's hot like this whole
journey I am now on the the bottom end
of the
hyperbole is that the right word no
parrot like
the curve bell curve yeah but what's the
word it sounds like hyper hyperbole
the
okay whatever I'm at the end of it and
I'm annoyed and I'm like you know what
stop like for real
be
stop
yeah I'm kind of overpeed I set up were
you really so under him no
yeah
but like I was playing along with
everyone like ah Pete Kim I'll speak
along I'm done playing along
okay player
are you ready for some our fifth and
final news is more happy couple news
it's the fifth and final story I haven't
done one of these in a while hit them
Claude it's the [__] what is it what is
It remix what is it it's the final story
Pete I shall play with your hyperboleo
longer
I want my dinner now
damn I want my lunch now you know what
me too what are you gonna have for lunch
great question I don't have anything
lined up but I think I should invest in
a lunch plan yeah I'm gonna head down to
that new have you have you been I've
been there I have been oh it's a
gorgeous new Cafe I know I kind of want
like a Claudia lunch like a bowl with
like chicken rice
rice salmon veggies
Bowl yeah that's what I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go down to the market table
damn I'm jealous I love a bowl a hot
bowl
a hot Market Bowl yeah
our fifth and final story some happy
couple news rumored romance for a while
but now it is confirmed that Larsa
Pippen and Marcus Jordan are together
Larsa is making the romance Instagram
official she posted a photo with Michael
Jordan's son Marcus on her grid
yesterday and said checks over Stripes
at Trophy Room Store
a lot to break down here okay is this
really a confirmation though because
they have had a friendship for a while
they were photographed leaving many
restaurants together and they've
maintained that it's friendship yes but
earlier this month there's pictures of
them kissing outside a hotel in South
Beach and I she's never like posted I
guess it could no I don't think that it
is they kissed they kissed outside a
hotel and there's Paparazzi pictures now
tell me the age difference so I can
judge accordingly
okay Marcus uh she's 48. and he is 32.
okay while it is a significant jump I do
think a 32 year old is capable of making
knows his mind their own decisions so
I'm not gonna I will I won't be
judgmental because it's okay yes but the
shade here is this caption checks over
Stripes because apparently checks is
like Nike and so like the Air Jordan is
part of Nike the Czech family Stripes
being Adidas and
Scottie Pippin is like an Adidas guy I
know I feel like Lars looks like is not
bitter about the Scotty thing like I've
never that's what I no no but that's
what I thought too and that's why this
is surprising because this is kind of
like a shady caption to her maybe it has
nothing to do with like when I think of
Adidas I don't think of Scottie Pippen
yeah wait I don't know where I got that
that he has anything to do maybe she's
just supporting Nike right like maybe
and Jordan or maybe that's like a song
lyric
or maybe it's like hold on let me search
Scottie Pippen Adidas maybe he's so far
out of my realm of like knowledge
nothing important is coming up so yeah
it's not a swipe at Scotty because that
I was going to say that's shocking too
she always speaks about Scott it was
such Reverend how their friends like
they didn't even need to bother getting
divorced like she says they just like
split everything and like walked away I
just want to say for me the most
shocking part of this conversation is
that Larson Pippen is 48 years old she
looks incredible
yeah she does
I think this is a really cute
relationship she's kept saying on the
show that she doesn't want to date
another athlete and even though Marcus
like played college basketball now he
owns like a high-end sneaker store so I
don't think this qualifies as an athlete
but I think she's still like
Sports adjacent which is what she likes
yeah no agreed I don't think this counts
as an athlete it's like a family member
of an athlete it is just weird because I
feel like Scottie Pippin his Nemesis was
Michael Jordan they were like the same
era of basketball so now like Scottie
Pippen's wife is dating his nemesis's
son like honestly good for her men do
that all the time 100 you're so right
you're so right and if it was a 48 year
old man and a 32 year old woman I
wouldn't even think about the age no
you're right you're so but also women
are just more mature than men like a 32
year old woman is like a 38 year old
woman you know
yes when you think about maturity to men
yes no you're so right not me being
biased
again
it happens but I'm really you know I
love Larsa and I just want love for her
and I'm glad she feels like good enough
in her relationship to share it with us
hopefully she'll share it on the show
yes
what more could you ask for okay that's
cute you know what now that we've talked
through I feel good about it yeah
and I feel like Lars is very particular
you know yes like I feel like if she was
your friend and you set her up on a
blind date like she would hate everyone
agreed and like she doesn't just bring a
lot of people around her kids like she
she's very particular about that yeah
and I think she's just very protective
because she's lived like a very big life
yeah and she's not just like someone who
has like people around so no and it's
probably nice to be with someone who
understands a life that big arguably a
bigger life Michael Jordan yeah yeah I
think there's a lot of common ground
yeah so it's nice
it's nice okay I'm glad that she wasn't
taking a swipe no at Scotty no I knew it
didn't sound right
very cool she's just supporting checks
now because she's part of the Jordan
family and honestly I would not be
surprised if checks over Stripes is like
a popular song lyric right now from like
a rap song I don't I don't keep up with
like rap lyrics I'm not I'm a Taylor
Swift encyclopedia and that's it but I
feel like people are always using like
new Drake songs as like their captions
yeah that's true it's just an idea I
feel like the article might have said
that and said they explained explicitly
how it was anti-adidus oh the article
was just trying to start stuff
yeah it it got me I fell for it well
that's our show and it might be our
first show in a year that's been under
an hour which is crazy
yeah no the episodes are so long it's so
crazy there's been a few that are like
58 minutes I was looking recently and it
was like last week we had like some 50
in the 50s but before that not since
November like can we ever shut up no we
literally don't shut them we don't even
do TV recap no I know what are we
talking about ourselves which is why our
episodes have been so good and where I'm
burdening ourselves
um so that is our show thank you guys so
much for listening and what's so
exciting is that by the next time you
hear our voices it'll be the middle of
the week like we'll be almost done so
just keep that in mind keep your head up
today okay thank you so much for
listening to the toaster wow look at
this positive motivational speaker thank
you so much for listening to the toast
the millennial Morning Show where we
deliver the past five stories that you
need to know every Monday through Friday
on YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
review about how beautiful stunning and
wickedly talented we are hope you guys
have an enclave Tuesday and we'll see
you on witness today bye love ya bye